foreign
hackers and state sponsors hyber Warfare
to ncds malware and data breaches the
dangers of the digital threat is ever
present threatening individuals
businesses and governments around the
world well guess what I'm talking about
you guess that right cyber threats of
course on that note hello everyone and
welcome to Simply learn in today's
session we'll be discussing what are
cyber attacks and various types of cyber
attacks prevented in today's times but
before we begin if you're into the
channel and haven't subscribed already
consider getting subscribed to our
Channel simply learn to stay updated
with all the latest Technologies and hit
that Bell icon to never miss an update
from us so without any further Ado let's
get started with today's topic
firstly let us have a quick introduction
to what cyber attacks are now the rise
of digital age has brought unprecedented
connectivity and convenience but it has
also introduced new avenues for
malicious actors to expert
vulnerabilities cyber attacks
encompasses a broad range of malicious
activities where adversities leverage
technology to infiltrate disrupt or
compromise digital systems and data so
in nutshell you can say it is a
deliberate and malicious attempt to
compromise computer networks networks
system devices with intention of causing
harm stealing sensitive information or
gaining any kind of unauthorized access
and having said that with cyber attacks
becoming more prevalent and severe it
has become crucial to address the cyber
security skill Gap and overcome the
shortage of cyber security Talent so if
you're interested in pursuing a career
in cyber security and acquiring the
necessary skills then our post-graduate
program and cyber security can be the
right option for you well gain expertise
repeat gain expertise in defensive and
offensive cyber security digital
forensics ethical hacking network
security penetration testing and crucial
domains with this internship program our
comprehensive program offers a
curriculum that income passes a wide
range of in-demand cyber security tools
Hands-On labs and greater practices and
throughout the course you will embark on
a well-structured Learning Journey
starting with fundamental cyber security
Concepts and progressing through asset
and inventory management offensive
security and defensive security to
ensure your Readiness for the industry
you'll also engage in multiple projects
allowing you to hone your skills and
emergency exceptional cyber security
professional furthermore this course
will help you learn comprehensive
approaches to protecting your
infrastructure and securing data in
mitigation compliance and much more so
why wait hurry up and sign the course
Link in the description box for more
details so make sure you check that out
and let us continue with our topic today
now
so what is the motive behind cyber
security attacks now that we wanted to
watch cyber security acts let us
understand what is the motive behind it
now the digital age as revolutionized
how we interact work and live but it has
also brought new challenges in fences
for victims now the motive behind
several attacks can be widely varied and
they are often driven by different
factors depending on the attackers goals
and intentions so let us look at some of
the motives behind cyber attacks now
first on the list we have financial gain
now one of the most prevalent repeat one
of the most prevalent motivation for
cyber attacks is financial gain they
seek to steal sensitive financial
information such as credit card details
login credentials or any kind of
personal data which they can sell on the
black market or used to commit fraud and
identity theft where attackers encrypt a
victim's data and demand payment for
decryption keys and also motivated by
Financial key
now second reason is industrial option
age now in the corporate world cyber
attacks is sometimes carried out to gain
a competitive Advantage by stealing
proprietary information Trade Secrets
and intellectual property competing
companies and Nation statewides May
Target organizations to obtain valuable
information and insights
political reasons or any kind of
ideological reasons now hacktivism
involves using cyber attacks as a mean
of expressing political or ideological
views hacktivists Target government
agencies corporations or other
organizations to protect or raise
awareness about specific issue they may
deface websites leak sensitive
information or disturb services to make
their points
personal Vendetta or any Revenge now
some cyber attacks are also carried out
by individuals seeking revenge or
retaliation against a person a group of
organization they hold a grudge against
and finally cyber terrorism now in rare
cases cyber attacks can be carried out
as an act of terrorism to create fear
chaos and widespread disruption these
attacks aim to cause significant harm to
society and can Target critical
infrastructure such as power grades or
Transport Systems and much more while
understanding the motives behind cyber
attacks help in developing effective
cyber security strategies to mitigate
and respond to these threats
now how does cyber attacks exactly
happen now cyber attacks are
orchestrated processes that aim to
compromise the security and integrity of
computer systems and Digital Data
attackers gather information about their
targets such as identifying potential
vulnerabilities security weaknesses and
valuable data they can exploit now this
phase involves passive techniques like
searching publicly available information
and active techniques like scanning for
open ports on the targets Network so
regular security assessment timely
software updates user awareness training
and implementing robust security
measures are essential in mitigating
these risk of cyber attacks from
happening
thus cyber criminals are constantly
devising their sophisticated techniques
to expert vulnerabilities in systems and
networks they reduce devastating online
questions for victim so understanding
these threats and implementing proactive
safety measures is crucial for
safeguarding our digital assets and
personal information so here are the
common types of fiber threats that are
provided in the current times in no
particular order now firstly on the list
we have malware now malware encompasses
various types of malicious software
designed to infiltrate systems data
steel and Reserve operations and gain
unauthorized access it includes various
types of uh viruses worms Trojans
ransomware and spiral Etc now malware
disguises itself as a legitimate files
or software to receive users and avoid
detection it can propagate through
infected email attachments malicious
websites or compromise software
now one of the real world example of
this is in 2017 the wanakai ransomware
attacked thousands of computers
worldwide and crypto data and demanding
Ransom payments in Bitcoin
so what are the consequences of malware
attack firstly data breaches and theft
of sensitive information
next we have system disruptions leading
to long time and kind of financial
losses
and thirdly Espionage and unauthorized
access to personal or corporate Networks
but how can you Safeguard yourself from
happening or protect yourself from
malware so firstly you need to regularly
update your operating systems and
software to patch vulnerabilities also
install reputable antivirus and ulti
malware software and keep them up to
date
thirdly
exercise caution when downloading files
from untrusted sources or clicking on
any unknown links from the websites or
Internet
finally educate users about safe project
practices and recognizing potential
Market threads
now second on the list we have phishing
attacks now phishing attacks are social
engineering techniques used by cyber
criminals to trick individuals into
revealing sensitive information such as
login credentials Financial details or
any personal data phishing emails often
appear to be from reputable sources
including bands social media platforms
or government agencies they create a
sense of urgency or fear to prompt
immediate actions so make sure you do
not click any sort of
uh unreputable sources of emails that
you get from any kind of understated
resources
now what are the consequences of
phishing attacks firstly identity theft
and unauthorized access to personal
accounts also Financial losses due to
fraudulent transactions by clicking uh
and
repeat
secondly Financial losses due to
fraudulent transactions by clicking
unknown links from various uh
third-party websites or such
and finally compromise of sensitive
business data and intellectual property
now in 2017 a phishing attack targeted
Gmail users directing them to a fake
login page to steal their credentials so
make sure you stay away from all these
malicious activities
so what are the safety measures you can
take against phishing attacks firstly
enable multi-factor authentication from
all accounts to add an extra layer of
security Now next trick avoid clicking
on any suspicious links as discussed
earlier so you have to train employees
and individuals to recognize facing
emails and avoid clicking on any sort of
unsuspicious links
also Implement email filtering systems
to detect and block phishing attempts
and finally regularly update your web
browsers to protect against known
phishing vulnerabilities by installing
any kind of anti-virus systems
the list we have ransomware now
ransomware is a type of malware that
encapes our victim's data making it
inaccessible until a ransom is paid to
the attackers a recipient threat to
individuals businesses and government
organizations worldwide now ransomware
often uses strong encryption algorithms
to lock victim's data securely it may be
delivered through malicious email
attachments compromised websites or
expert kits now in 2021 the colonial
pipeline in the United States fell
Victory toward ransomware attack leading
to the shutdown of operation and a
ransom payment to the attackers
so what are the consequences of
ransomware again now again Financial
losses due to Ransom payments can be a
huge Factor where you have to pay a lots
of lots and amounts of payment or money
to the hackers
data loss and potential leakage or
sensitive information and finally
reputation damage to organizations that
experience the successful attacks of
ransomware so what are the safety
measures that you can take against
ransomware well you can regularly backup
critical data to an offline or secure
location to avoid data loss also
maintain up-to-date data software and
security patches to protect against
known vulnerabilities
Implement network settings
repeat Implement Network segmentation to
contain the spread of ransomware within
the system and finally train your
employees and individuals to exercise
cautions when handling email attachments
and links and by regularly security
audits repeat and by connecting regular
security audits you can protect yourself
from various kinds of ransomware attacks
now fourth on the list we have DDOS or
distributed denial of service attacks
now DDOS attacks aims to overload
targets online services or networks by
flooding them with a massive amounts of
traffic rendering them inaccessible to
legitimate users these hackers are
typically orchestrated using botnets now
the DDOS attacks use multiple devices to
create a massive volume of traffic
causing service disruptions attackers
often exploit vulnerable iot devices to
build botlands but what are the
consequences of DDOS attacks firstly
let's say downtime and service
disruptions leading to financial losses
secondly damage to a company's
reputation and customer trust if you
know in 2018 GitHub experienced one of
the largest DDOS attacks in history with
traffic peaking at 1.35 tbps and in 2016
a massive bdos attacker or Des provider
disrupted several major websites and
services
and finally
server and website vulnerability
now diversion of attention from the
actual attack to dealing with the
aftermath of this can also be a crucial
consequence where if your server or
website vulnerability has already been
caused
so what are the safety measures against
radiois's firstly deploy tracking
filtering repeat deploy track repeat
deploy traffic filtering and lay
trembling to detect and block malicious
traffic during an attack
utilize content delivery networks or
cdns to distribute traffic across
multiple servers and reduce the impact
of DDOS attacks also regularly monitored
traffic and setup allows for unusual
patterns indicating an ongoing attack
invest in scalable infrastructure to
handle sudden traffic surges and prevent
service disruptions so these are some of
the safety measures that you can take
against DDOS attacks and help yourself
to protect against them
and finally on the list we have SQL
injection SQL injection is a web
application vulnerability that allows
attackers to manipulate the website's
data by injecting malicious SQL code
into input Fields this can lead to
unauthorized Access Data Theft or data
manipulation now the SQL injection is
successful the database might execute
the attacker's injected SQL code
alongside the legitimate query granting
unauthorized access to data modifying
alternating data or even compromising
the entire database so SQL injection
applies repeat SQL injection exploits
poorly sanitized user inputs and
replication
repeat SQL induction expires poorly
sanitized user inputs in web
applications which can extract modify or
delete data from affected databases so
what are the consequences of SQL
injection well unauthorized access to
sensitive data including user
credentials and personal information
secondly data manipulation or deletion
rendered data and rigidity issues and
finally disclosure of confidential
information and compliance violation now
a real life example of SQL injection is
in 2008 SQL injection was used to breach
Heartland Payment Systems resulting in a
theft of millions of credit card records
so what are the safety measures that you
can dig against SQL injection firstly
adopt secure coding practices such as
parameterized queries and input
validation to prevent SQL injection
vulnerabilities from happening secondly
conduct regular security assessments and
penetration testing to identify and
address potential SQL injection flaws
next implement the principle of least
privilege to limit database access
rights for application users so that the
hackers cannot easily
dive into your database
and finally stay updated on the latest
security patches and updates for
Frameworks and applications so these
were some of the top five common types
of cyber security threats that are
prevalent through its times let's see
what we have at number 10. from April 27
2007 Estonia the European country faced
a series of cyber attacks that lasted
for weeks this happened when the
Estonian government decided to move the
bronze soldier from Talon Center to a
less prominent military cemetery located
on the city's outskirts
unprecedented levels of internet traffic
took down Estonian Banks online services
media Outlets broadcasters and
government bodies botnet sent massive
waves of spam and vast amounts of
automated Online requests according to
researchers the public faced DDOS
attacks there were conflicts to edit the
English language version of The Bronze
soldiers Wikipedia page as well although
there is no confirmation Russia is
believed to be behind these cyber
attacks that largely crippled the
Estonian Society let's now move on to
the next attack on December 23 2015
several parts of Ukraine witnessed a
power outage and this was not a typical
blackout it was indeed the result of a
Cyber attack
Information Systems of three energy
distribution companies in Ukraine were
compromised it is the first known
Victorious Cyber attack on a power grid
it is said that here hackers sent out
phishing emails to the power companies
30 substations were Switched Off and
about 230 000 people were left in the
dark for about one to six hours U.S
investigators believed that russia-based
hackers were responsible for this
experts have warned that other countries
could also be vulnerable to such attacks
let's see what we have at number eight
in the year 1999 a Cyber attack cost a
21-day shutdown of NASA computers
unbelievable isn't it the hacker was
none other than the then 15 year old
Jonathan James he first penetrated U.S
Department of Defense divisions
computers and installed a back door on
its servers this allowed him to
intercept more than a thousand
government emails including the ones
containing usernames and passwords this
helped James steal a piece of NASA
software and crack the NASA computers
that support the International Space
Station which caused a space exploration
agency's forty one thousand dollars
assistance were shut down for three
weeks
he was the first person to carry out a
computer hack against the American space
agency let's now move on to the next
attack in late November 2014 there was a
leak of confidential data from the film
studio of Sunni pictures
information about Sony Pictures
employees their emails copies of the
then unreleased Sony films future
propositions and other crucial data were
leaked this Cyber attack was carried out
by a hacker grouped named Guardians Of
Peace so what did the hackers want well
they demanded that Sony withdraw its
then upcoming movie the interview this
movie was a comedy story line to
assassinate the North Korean leader Kim
Jong-un Sony then decided to cancel the
film's theatrical release due to their
threats at Cinema screening the movie it
is indeed hard to trace the roots of a
Cyber attack in this case after
evaluation the U.S intelligence
officials arrived at the theory that the
attack was in a way related to the
government of North Korea
however North Korea had denied the same
moving on to our number six in December
2006 TJX the U.S retailer company
identified that 45.6 million debit and
credit card details were stolen
this happened from one of its systems
over 18 months by an unknown number of
intruders it was one of the first
largest ever cyber attacks involving the
loss of personal data as a result banks
in the affected regions had to reissue
and block thousands of payment cards a
group of hackers did this Albert
Gonzalez being The Mastermind the group
was from Miami the place where the TJX
Heist was believed to have originated
reports said that the TJX data breach
occurred because of weak web encryption
at two of its martial stores in Miami
next moving on to our top five let us
see what we have at number five the year
2010 witnessed the discovery of the
deadly computer worm stuxnet this
malware's motive was unlike any other
usual cyber attacks it aimed at
destructing the equipment the computers
controlled
stuxnet came with the deadly purpose of
damaging Iran's nuclear infrastructure
it infected more than 200 000 computers
including 14 Industrial sites and a
uranium enrichment plant in Iran
stuxnet initially spread via Microsoft
Windows and targeted Siemens industrial
control systems
although it was discovered only in 2010
It is believed to have been silently
sabotaging Iran's nuclear facilities
it was one of the first discovered
malware that was capable of hampering
hardware systems it largely damaged the
centrifuges of the Iranian reactors this
is believed to be a cyber weapon created
by the US and the Israeli intelligence
although there is no documented evidence
or acceptance by either of the countries
for the same moving on to number four in
the year 2014 Home Depot was the victim
of one of the deadliest cyber attacks 56
million payment cards were compromised
along with 53 million customer email
addresses stolen
this security breach happened from April
to September 2014. criminals were
believed to have used a third party
vendors username and password to enter
the perimeter of Home Depot's Network
the attackers were then able to deploy
custom-built malware on its
self-checkout systems in the U.S and
Canada
moving on to our top three
as you might be aware the PlayStation
gaming system is one of Sony's most
popular products unfortunately in April
2011 Sony Executives witnessed abnormal
activity on the PlayStation Network this
resulted in the compromise of
approximately 77 million PlayStation
users accounts and prevented users of
PlayStation 3 and PlayStation Portable
consoles from accessing this service
this forced Sony to turn off the
PlayStation Network on April 20th on May
4th Sony confirmed that personally
identifiable information from each of
the 77 million accounts had been exposed
the outage lasted for 23 days Sony
released almost daily announcements
concerning the system outage in the end
Sony is believed to have invested
approximately 170 million dollars to
improve the network security to
investigate the attack and to cover the
expenses of caring for the consumers
that had been affected let's now move on
to the next attack at number two in May
2017 one of the most dangerous cyber
attacks took place
it was known as the Warner cry
ransomware attack caused by the wannacry
crypto worm the victims were the users
that used the unsupported version of
Microsoft Windows and those who hadn't
installed the new security update
this did not take place through fishing
like other attacks but through an
exposed vulnerable SMB port
the attack originated in Asia and then
eventually spread across the globe in a
day more than 200 000 computers were
infected across 150 countries
the wannacry cry crypto worm locked the
users out of the targeted systems and
encrypted their data the users were
asked for a ransom of 300 to 600 dollars
which had to be paid via Bitcoin in
exchange for their data this attack took
a toll on both private and government
organizations it resulted in Damages
from hundreds of millions to billions of
dollars in a matter of few days the
emergency patches released by Microsoft
halted the attack also the discovery of
a kill switch prevented the infected
computers from spreading the crypto worm
Security Experts in a few countries
believed that North Korea was behind
this attack and finally let's see what
we have at number one more than two
decades ago in March 1999 the Melissa
virus a mass mailing macro virus was
released it targeted Microsoft Word and
outlook-based systems and created
considerable Network traffic Melissa
virus infected computers via emails the
email would look like an important
message well yes it was fake if the
recipient opens the attachments in the
mail and downloads the document and then
opens it with Microsoft Word a virus was
released on their computers
this would then Mass mail itself to the
first 50 people in the victim's contact
list and then disable multiple Safeguard
features on Microsoft Word and Microsoft
Outlook this began spreading like a
wildfire across the internet David L
Smith released the virus the virus cost
nearly 80 million worth of Damages it
did not steal data or money however it
cost a Havoc almost 1 million email
accounts were disrupted worldwide
agencies were overloaded and some had to
be shut down entirely and internet
traffic in some locations were slowed
down so with that we come to the end of
this video on the top 10 computer hacks
of all time do you agree with our list
if you're aware of any other great
interesting computer hacks in history do
let us know in the comment section below
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
thank you